Speaker 1: Ted Cruz appeared on The Laura
Ingraham Show on Fox News last night,
and this is if you were to look
up projection in the dictionary,
it should have an interactive video clip of Ted
Cruz's appearance on Fox News last night. So let
me set this up for you. One of the phenomena that
we've noticed with Republicans over the last five
or six years is whenever they really start harping
on Democrats are doing X or Democrats will do X.
We need to very seriously look at whether what
they mean is we are doing this or we plan to do
this, and I'll give you some examples. Donald
Trump and I know many of you have heard this.
Donald Trump said. So many times we can't
vote for Hillary in 2016 because she can't
be trusted with her email. She's using personal
email. She can't be trusted with classified and
secret information and on and on. And it really
didn't make sense. And it was actually Trump who
planned to do all of those very things. Trump
completely untrustworthy with secret information
from allies spilling secrets from allies to
a Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office.
Many in Trump's inner circle, including
Mark Meadows, Ivanka Trump, Jared Kushner,
using private email while they were working for
Donald Trump, Trump eating notes that are supposed
to be preserved as records Trump power flushing 10
to 15 times notes that are supposed to be kept for
presidential records. So when he starts talking,
when they start talking about the left is going
to do this thing, we should be like, Are they
actually doing it? And often the answer is yes.
For six months, Trump saying they're going to do
fraud in the 2020 election. We can't do vote by
mail, whether they're going to win and they're
going to steal it and all this different stuff.
And of course, it was. Trump and his acolytes who
filed 60 frivolous legal complaints, insisted that
vans and machines and all these different things
mean that they actually had the election stolen
from them. They were the ones trying to steal
the election. So now with that context in mind?
Listen to what we're. Straight face,
Ted Cruz says last night on Fox News
he has no shame list. Listen very closely.
Speaker 5: I cannot accept it as a result.
They know they're going to lose.
And Nancy Pelosi is not going to
go quietly. She's going to scream. She's
already preparing to scream. The election
was stolen. And by the way, what she
means by stolen is people showed up
to vote against Democrats. That's what
stealing the election is. And remember,
Democrats don't believe in democracy.
Speaker 1: This how can you say this with
a straight face? This is exactly what they did
in 2020, when they said in 2020 it was stolen.
What it was was that more Democrats came out to
vote. That's that's what happened when they say
Nancy Pelosi is planning to claim it was stolen.
No, that's what you guys did. And that's exactly
what they're going to do again, depending on the
results in November. Here's a bonus Ted Cruz clip
here, where he complains he hasn't
spoken with Joe Biden personally,
and that that's like a problem in some way.
Speaker 5: You know the question you just
asked Eric. I actually get asked that almost every
day somebody says, who's really running things?
And let me tell you the scary thing. I have no
idea. So Biden's been president, what, 15 months
in that entire time. I have not spoken with
him once, and that's true of almost every
Republican senator. I've got to say that's weird.
Speaker 1: Why does Biden have to speak to them to
show he's really the president? Why would Biden
speak to Ted Cruz? Ted Cruz is out of his mind,
and this is a really new common thing on the
right. Kyle Rittenhouse has also been polling
this. Clearly, Joe Biden is doing something wrong
because he hasn't met with Kyle Rittenhouse. I
think why would Biden meet with Kyle Rittenhouse
Speaker 4: or is calling you out on Twitter?
What would you like them to know
most about your story, right?
Speaker 6: Yeah, I was attacked. I was 17 years
old. I was attacked and had to defend myself
and not a racist, not a white supremacist. I'm
not a domestic terrorist. I'm not a murderer.
And anybody who wants to sit
down and have a conversation,
I'm more than open. I reached out to Joe Biden
several times. Crickets. Nothing. He still hasn't
replied. So it just shows how much of a man he
is to not sit down to talk to a 19 year old.
Speaker 1: Why does Joe Biden have to talk to Kyle
Rittenhouse? Why does Joe Biden have to talk to
Ted Cruz? These people are so self-centered
thinking everything is about them. It is
truly unbelievable. But Ted Cruz, apparently
with absolutely no sense of irony or shame
showing up and saying, Guys, if we're not
careful, Democrats might try to claim they won,
even though they didn't know well, they'd be
taking a lesson from you. Wouldn't they, Ted?